we're gonna need some anger management
classes up at the White House axios out
with a very unflattering headline about
President Biden's management style
saying this Old Yeller Biden's private
Fury AIDS recounting how the president
has an explosive temper and is prone to
yelling it's so bad that some try to
avoid one-on-one meetings so they don't
get chewed up with these colorful
phrases quote like this how the bleep
don't you know this don't leaping Bowl
bleep me and get the bleep out of here
sounds like exclamation point show I
think so it is behavior that's
definitely at odds with the day one
warning to staff remember this
I'm not joking when I say this
if you're ever working with me and I
hear you treat another colleague with
disrespect
talk down to someone I promise you I
will fire you on the spot
on the spot
nowhere fans or buts
and while White House staffers cow are
in the corner at least there's one new
person in his Corner AOC is now the
first member of the progressive Squad to
back Biden's re-election run even if it
was reluctantly
will you be supporting Joe Biden for
re-election I believe given that feel
yes I think he's done quite well uh
given the limitations that we have
but you know there are also areas that I
think
could have gone better we have major
structural issues in this country and it
starts I think it starts with the United
States Senate the other thing that
happened over the weekend it's like when
we talk about how Biden ends up Greg
getting well the Democrats had like the
bad signal that goes out that says now
we're all going to say this well it
turns out it looks like they are all
coming to the consensus and I was with a
bunch of Democrats over the weekend that
they feel that Biden should step down
here's a headline from the Atlantic step
aside Joe Biden what's happening where
were you this weekend with a bunch of
Democrats and Republicans too but I was
I was surprised by how the consensus it
just seemed to be that he should resign
so this is very strange for me because
when I see the media and the mainstream
media and liberals turn on Biden then
it's time to support him yeah because
they must be having something else
that's far worse in store uh because
they never have anything better so I'm
beginning to worry that what are they
going to do are they is it Gavin Newsom
is it Kamala are they going to bring
back Satan her South Hillary Clinton I
don't know now I'm a fan of his
exploding temper I I can't get enough of
it and then you have AOC
who you know we know Joe's incapacitated
uh uh we're not supposed to mention the
dementia but let's face it these these
blow-ups are a sign of somebody with
dementia we're not supposed to say that
you could say that Trump was insane
remember when he was mad the 25th
Amendment but if you actually say
anything about this kind of anger stuff
that's bad but uh we know he's a
brainless hood ornament
that's why AOC likes him so AOC
endorsing him is basically saying we
need more of that because he will never
get in the way of our Progressive agenda
far left agenda and lastly I was told
that he was a nice person I was told he
was your congenial Grandpa and now
you're telling me that was a big lie and
he's actually a real meanie I mean who
would have thought the media would have
done that I mean I am shocked
the other thing that happened is he was
did an interview he did an interview
Jesse with CNN and Mr Reed Zakaria who
after a fashion asked him about his age
here's what President Biden said
I think I
there is one thing that comes with age
if you're been honest about it your
whole life and that is some wisdom
I think we're on the cusp of being able
to make significant positive changes in
the world really honest to God you just
celebrated a birthday and are a year
wiser yes do you agree that wiser with
age do I look wiser a little bit a
little bit I don't know Joe Biden and
wisdom do not belong in the same
sentence together
there are two types of people there are
the frauds and then there are the people
that are the Real Deals if you're the
real deal you act the same in public as
you do in private
Blake Gutfeld he is just as obnoxious on
camera as he is off camera same with
Trump he doesn't change no matter if
people are looking at him or no one else
is in the room he's the same person Joe
Biden is a fraud Joe Biden is not a
family man you don't send your son who's
addicted to drugs to China to bring home
cash bribes for the rest of the family
you don't say you're a family man and
just ignore this granddaughter and you
can't be the seasoned Elder Statesman
that's calm and making great decisions
for this nation and then just be blowing
your lid he doesn't ever get angry about
the Border or about criminals preying on
us or about high prices he only gets
angry when you zero in on his fraudulent
personality oh you're challenging me
you're challenging me you talking about
my son that's when he gets his guard up
and also he's not poor and middle class
he's been making it rain for two decades
so that's also totally fraudulent
and now the Atlantic this publication
that's owned by Steve Jobs's Widow he's
been trying to throw corporate welfare
at this woman for years he's been trying
to kiss her butt for donations for years
she doesn't want to have anything to do
with them so she wants them gone and
looks like CNN's trying to break up with
him in a nice way like maybe we should
see other people yes you had a good run
as if they were saying if you if you
were to resign gracefully we will
applaud you on your way out and we will
consider you a hero right but instead
judge the other thing that's happening
is you had Maureen Dowd who's a New York
Times columnist from the left she has a
sister named Peggy who really has loved
Joe Biden but she wrote him a letter and
in the letter basically the headline
from The New York Times piece is
um do we have it here can you pull it up
here it's seven grandkids Mr President
and the kicker of that at the end of the
column is that he is not living up to
the image that he wants to project as a
family man yeah and I think that one of
the interesting things that she said is
the president can't defend Hunter on all
his messes and draw the line on an
innocent four-year-old granddaughter you
know Joe Biden is more than hypocritical
the man is a trojan horse we never
really knew who he was he he was a
moderate he was this or that and he
turns out to be a progressive who was in
cognitive decline I mean the outbursts
and the unprovoked attacks and people
working for him now apparently are
walking on eggshells there's totally
petrified he's screaming at people we
saw it during the campaign he would say
to someone you know get down and what
let's do push-ups we'll go out in the
back and we'll do push-ups and you
wonder if he had a meeting with Xi
Jinping and he loses his cool what's it
going to say to him you know he's going
to start screaming at him and cursing at
him and then the other thing is the the
whole idea of this family guy with the
granddaughter I mean it makes me it
really upsets me Dana and I know it
upsets you too but you've got a
four-year-old and all of them America
knows her I think all of America feels
badly for there are so many American
families who are in similar situations
it's almost as though we should send a
gift to the White House for Navy Roberts
so that maybe at the White House they'll
understand how many Americans are so
concerned about this grandchild and
finally I think that for all the people
who are working for this man they're not
working at the Peak Performance because
you can't be when you're walking on
those eggshells and where you're getting
cursed out and you've got a vice
president who's got a toxic atmosphere
at her office I mean the whole thing two
of them are just absolutely the opposite
of what we thought they were I do want
to show everybody The View has figured
out a way to defend the president about
the granddaughter watch
should be directed to Hunter Biden it's
five children not four Hunter because
this is not Joe Biden's baby the right
wing and the Maga world has decided to
weaponize Hunter Biden against his dad
Maureen down to find something else to
write about yeah they write about
something else I find it
unnecessary this is not anybody's
business nobody needed to know about
this this is private oh so let's hide it
exactly so Harold uh you could comment
on that but also if you could tell me
have you also heard from some Democrats
that they think if Joe Biden were to
resign that would be a welcome
development for Democrats not resign I'm
sorry step aside from reelection I think
Marine downspace is a powerful piece um
and I'll leave it at that
um I too hear Democrats saying what
you're hearing what you're what you
heard that that they wish the president
would not run again for a lot of reasons
that have been articulated around a
table over many many days uh that he was
a conciliator and brought people
together I think if you look at a lot of
the polling data In fairness
um the majority of Americans hope
there's not a Biden Trump rematch that
they hope that there's something new
something different that emerges and
that people have more choices and
frankly as I look at the the landscape
one thing for certain the supporters of
Mr Trump and the supporters of Mr Biden
uh bring out the worst in one another
which means we bring out the worst in
the country so if the Atlantic is right
and if I hear from a lot of people most
of the people I'm hearing from are
wealthier people or people whom are in
business and people who believe that the
president may may have lost some of his
faculties uh we'll see as this campaign
goes on it'll be an opportunity I've
contended that if if Robert Kennedy Jr I
know you're interviewing tonight if he
continues to poll as well as he pull has
polled I think you're going to probably
invite perhaps other candidates into the
race President Biden won't be the first
isn't the first and won't be the last to
uh to to have temper tantrums with his
staff I think in any job politics
business Academia you have to sit back
at the end of the day and take account
of yourself and all I was you know
people may say I yell at times I want to
see that
how do we do it but you have but you
have to sit back and whether you're yell
or don't you have to sit back and take
stock and uh wonder whether you advance
your agenda or whether you got us to
Higher Ground and I hope that everyone
does that including the president uh and
others for president
I'm Gonna Leave everybody with one more
thing how do you know that the media is
starting to think this not only the
axios piece Maureen Dowd everybody but
the view is on board apparently but
Politico did a big piece today called
Welcome to the Newsome verse Oh and it
highlighted all of the amazing staffers
who work for governor Newsome because
apparently you need to know who they are
wow all right hi winner Brian Kilmeade I
want you to do me a favor I want you to
click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now